[Music]
Kim Kardashian dances with her daughter
North to Taylor Swift's Shake It Off I
love Taylor Swift I'm the biggest Taylor
Swift fan and lip syncs to scissors Kill
Bill on tick tock
[Music]
is anyone else getting the feeling she
could be sending a message to her ex
Kanye West I'll voice my opinion when I
think that there's something that you
know has made me done wrong on Thursday
the mommy daughter Duo shared this clip
to their joint Tick Tock account having
a blast with the help of Miss Swift
[Music]
I think you know social media is such a
great tool and while the clip is super
cute fans are a little surprised by the
Music Choice given Kim's ex Kanye West's
long time Feud with Taylor stemming from
this moment at the 2009 MTV VMAs when
yay interrupted the singer's acceptance
speech I'm really happy for you I'm let
you finish but Beyonce had one of the
best videos of all time I was really
excited because Kanye West was on the
stage and then I um then I wasn't so
excited anymore
after that then in 2016 yay name dropped
Taylor and his single famous I feel like
me and Taylor might still have sex why I
made that [ __ ] famous Taylor publicly
slammed the track and shortly after Kim
released clips of a phone call between
her then husband and Taylor filmed
without Taylor's knowledge seemingly
confirming that Taylor gave the Grammy
winner permission to say her name in the
song a few years later the full call was
leaked revealing Kanye never told Taylor
about this line I made that [ __ ] famous
and while Taylor has shied away from
addressing the beef fans speculate that
songs like look what you made me do look
what you just made me do and vigilante
contain references about the rapper you
should be thick as thieves with your ex
wife
Kim filed for divorce from Kanye in 2021
after six years of marriage and their
split was finalized in November I don't
want to get emotional no it's just been
a day for me
but like you know it's hard
it's like co-parenting it's really hard
you know the reality star recently
opened up about the struggles that come
with raising kids with an ex during a
chat on the Angie Martinez IRL podcast
if I'm in a petty Moon
I'll go back and I'll be like okay I
have all the receipts you know but then
I go back to my babies
and I think they will see
if they'll feel my energy well on
Thursday Kim's energy was upbeat singing
These lyrics from sza's track Kill Bill
[Music]
and while we don't know if all that was
directed at her ex A source told ET last
month that the two are legally in a
better place since their divorce was
finalized the former couple shares four
children together nine-year-old daughter
North seven-year-old son Saint
four-year-old daughter Chicago and
three-year-old son Psalm they'll share
joint custody of their kids with equal
access though Kim will have the kids
majority of the time
[Music]
foreign